and most importantly most importantly
we need to lap up the remaining leftist
tears if biden is going to ascend
i hope he doesn't but if he if he is to
ascend if the system is just so stacked
against trump
that that he can't overcome it we at
least need to lap up the remaining
leftist tears and that comes to us
by way of stephen colbert who is so
heartbroken that donald trump won't just
roll over
so we all knew he would do this
all right there they go here come the
waterworks
oh wow his head's down hand on his hip
i can't can't believe it so awful
what i didn't know is that it would hurt
so much
i didn't expect this to break my heart
for him to cast a dark shadow on our
most sacred right
from the briefing room in the white
house our house not his
that is devastating this
this is heartbreaking for the same
reason that
i didn't want him to get covet certainly
why i wanted him to survive
because he is the president of the
united
states that office means something and
that office should have some shred of
decency
it's so heartbreaking that trump would
cast a shadow over our most sacred right
and institution
voting you know cast a shadow like we
have done relentlessly
for four years and blamed russia and the
macedonians
and this and that and this and that
and not granted even for a second that
trump legitimately won in 2016.
so heartbreaking that trump would also
raise legitimate questions about the
election
heart so hard cry me a river steven
cry me a river of crocodile tears
because i
am not going to believe for even one
second
that this is a genuine uh sadness
the sadness is that you thought that you
all could kick out the orange man
without us raising even one question to
the
very distinct possibility of illegal
activity
well actually we have proof of the
illegal activity at least in philly
you thought we would roll over and we're
not going to do it sorry buster
we're not going to do that one little
bit
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode
linked in the description or download
the podcast wherever you listen to
[Music]
podcasts
[Music]
you